what it do citizens of the reject nation
greg here today we got ourselves a
teaser trailer for the last of us the
hbo max series adaptation a show i am
actually really looking forward to it's
one that i've talked about and you know
in speculation theory what we're looking
forward to the bunch of my front like a
couple there's only a few people i
actually know that are really into this
game because i i played the first game i
i loved it i loved the second game too i
know that's not the popular opinion on
youtube but i did a whole in-depth
spoiler review about the second game
right here on this very channel i
figured after checking out whatever this
teaser has to offer could share some of
those thoughts with you all that i've
talked about with a couple of my buddies
y'all can leave a like that'd be great i
downloaded the 30 second one because uh
i got word from my fiance that it was
like
part of one of those ooh look what's
coming to hbo max and maybe david
zasloff won't cancel most of these i got
this one which i'm assuming is just the
cut down version of what was featured
the snippets for the last
[Music]
has either died
or left me
you have no idea what laws is
spores
[Applause]
by the way we did a reaction for house
of the dragon that's why i'm running
late to this hey that was cool so short
he does sound like it does sound like
joel sounds like good old troy baker
there her saying though she's saying the
lines ella's saying the lines she's
saying the things from the video game
this teaser to me it's like okay this is
going to satisfy the last of us video
game fans because this is what it's
really riffing on here in terms of like
setting aesthetic the appearances of the
characters getting our first look and
hearing the voices of joel and ellie is
this little girl
who joel is carrying is that
is that's sarah i need a i'm gonna go on
youtube and and twitter
and i'll just go to wikipedia really
quick wow that is sarah oh man well i
don't want to spoil
[ __ ] for people who haven't played the
game oh man
there's a lot of people happy about the
fact that
they cast a little black girl you know
what it's time the real rejects joins
the anti-woke crowd i feel like it'd
just be much easier to get that
engagement going but you know what i
don't care that they cast a little black
girl you know what bothers me
the fact that they got a goddamn mexican
to play to play joel
instead of a a whitey white white just
kidding it's the part of the satire i
know pedro pascal's not even mexican
he's chilliam speaking of which i heard
gabriel luna is going to be playing his
brother tommy in this series and i am
excited for you know having pedro pascal
and gabriel luna share the screen
together yeah i mean okay it's a real
simple reasoning for why sarah's black
the mother is black all right bam plain
and simple jeff goldblum had like a full
black daughter in the lost world and i
didn't hear anyone complaining it's not
a big deal get over it but yeah i think
pedro pascal it was one of those casting
choices where it wasn't one of the first
people i thought of but just knowing the
work this man has done and how much of a
chameleon of an actor he is like he's
phenomenal and funny enough i feel like
there is some similar parallels between
joel's journey and that of the
mandalorian for guys who don't know the
story of the last of us the very nuts
and bolts version of this is that it
takes place in a post-apocalyptic future
it's not exactly as it's not a zombie
world but it's kind it's like a
virus-infected world it's kind of a
hodgepodge of things like the crazies
and some zombie stuff and then you know
like resident evil all sort of smashed
together so what's going on is you have
a hardened survivor in the form of joel
and then he comes across ellie he's
tested he's assigned to basically take
her across the states together to this
uh hidden camp of a group called the
fireflies you find out very early on
this might already be in the plot
synopsis is not a spoiler it's just a
part of the plot set up with this crazy
virus that has been wiping out the world
ellie while infected has not turned and
she might actually be the cure you have
this traumatized survivor taking care of
a child and he's really cold and can let
her in and can't be vulnerable and it's
kind of like mando he just has his jobs
in this you know like desolate
landscapes is a loner you know a lone
wolf and one day comes across this child
that he has to take across lands
and then there's some special dna inside
of that child and through that journey
both joel and mando learn to get in
touch with their fatherly side and learn
to be more vulnerable and in tune with
their emotions very different tones very
different worlds and it'll be very
different performances despite those
similarities but i'm looking forward to
it and you know the thing with pedro is
that joel is the is the role that you
could fan cast a bunch of people to play
him ellie's the hard one because ellie
is so much like elliot page like that's
just who you think of when you see ellie
especially the first time you play the
game that's a much harder role to
satisfy because like when i'm watching
the footage here of uh what's her name
uh she's she is
mormont from uh game of thrones uh bella
ramsay this is not making me think of
you know the video game portrayal of
ellie i feel like she's gonna be doing
something different but she does have a
harder task to truly make it her own due
to the fact that people would instantly
compare her to something like elliott
page it's much harder when you have a
character where like the the main
reoccurring joke or if it was deliberate
she is inspired by elliot page could be
wrong about that bottom line is she has
that comparison to live up to and then
lee paige fantastic actor but i think
she'll do a great job she's a wonderful
wonderful child actor who the hell is
nick offerman
i don't know who nick offerman's like
bill
who's bill god it's been so long since i
played this game hold on let me look up
a photo oh bill
yes i vaguely remember actually
what i do remember nick offered his
perfect casting for that character what
i believe in the video game is that joel
is owed a favor from bill and bill is
very much a loner has traps set
everywhere and it's it's like when you
think of imagine nick offerman in a
post-apocalyptic world and the kind of
character nick off from him would play
that's bill so i think that's actually
perfect casting for that and i've always
said that i think that if you're going
to make a video game adaptation the best
way to do it especially for these ones
that already feel like a movie is to do
a television series with the budgets the
tv shows get now with how much more
involved and intimate intricate the
specificity and the expansion you could
do on a tv series that way you're not
just trying to like cram a video game
into two to three hours you can really
go full force and adapt the video game
faithfully and even extend upon it as
well and the fact that they got neil
druckmann back here to write this show
as well i feel like this could be a
really solid video game adaptation like
last of us is one that when you play
that game you go hey that that could be
a movie but as an hbo show that's more
exciting for me and i feel like if you
are a fan of this game this should be
the ground that you should you got to be
more excited to explore within can't
wait for a full trailer the shot like i
want to see some clickers let's get some
clickers in here but i like the shot of
the spores this is gonna be a a good
time holy crap i love the mood all right
guys leave your thoughts down below
thank you so much for being here i'll
talk with you all soon
slap happy
you